we see all of anders in the latest  hogwarts legacy trailer which must mean  that diagon alley is in right well not  exactly you see back when they built the  harry potter theme park in orlando  florida they started out with only  hogsmeade and hogwarts realizing the  importance of park goers to have an  opportunity to get their own wand they  got it approved to put an ollivander's  branch in hogsmeade and it appears that  this is the branch of ollivanders we see  in hogwarts legacy if you look at this  specific shot here and then the cut here  you can see that hogwarts is there in  the background a similar shot of  ollivanders also appeared back when they  originally delayed the game from 2021 to  2022 and in that one you can also see  hogwarts in the background so now you  can see why seeing this olivanders  doesn't automatically guarantee we'll be  seeing diagon alley in hogwarts legacy